buenas tardes es un hecho sin
precedentes en el reino unido- y que sin
duda pone a tambalear a boris johnson
frente a downing street- como lo
comentas la policía metropolitana ha
encontrado que johnson su esposa car y
su ministro de finanzas rompieron las
reglas del confinamiento por la pandemia
de kobe 19 en el 2020 es un hecho muy
muy grave que pone aún más en riesgo la
autoridad y credibilidad del primer
ministro en este caso boris johnson
también de acuerdo con la investigación
de la policía se aprobaría mintió en
varias oportunidades al parlamento
porque negó haber asistido a estas
fiestas por ahora su futuro político
está en manos de su partido el
conservador que podría si lo quiere
convocar a una moción de confianza para
removerlo de su cargo pero hasta el
momento el partido no se ha pronunciado
pero por supuesto esta es una noticia de
gran impacto que se conocerán y se
desarrollará en las próximas horas luisa
y también la oposición ya reaccionó
pidiendo entonces la dimisión del primer
ministro que más se sabe sobre esta
petición de la oposición
sí desde que explotó este escándalo del
partido y el partido laborista que es el
más grande en oposición ha pedido la
renuncia de boris johnson porque no es
la persona más confiable dice el jefe
del partido decir que esta arma para
liderar el país pero también no y se ha
reafirmado ese llamado para que no
solamente johnson sino el ministro de
finanzas den un paso al costado luego de
que fueran encontrados culpables por la
policía pero también los
liberales-demócratas en las últimas
horas han pedido que el parlamento
británico sea convocado de manera
urgente porque están en receso de semana
santa hasta la próxima semana para que
se agotaba una moción de confianza para
que boris johnson sea removido de su
cargo hasta el momento el parlamento el
'speaker' no se ha pronunciado sobre
esta posibilidad pero lo cierto es que
es un momento bien delicado que los
diputados conservadores están tratando
con manos de seda porque aunque quieren
seguir ganando elecciones en el futuro
lo cierto es que en las últimas semanas
johnson se ha mostrado como un líder
internacional tratando de unir a la otan
y europa en contra de rusia y algunos
analistas con los que ha hablado
aseguran que este no sería el momento
más adecuado para cambiar de líder pero
lo cierto es que es un hecho grave que
seguramente tendrá consecuencias